naizain que atteint le fond ce sont des
valeurs humaines il a révolutionné le
photojournalisme et il a vendu près de
600 me livre antoine désilets est une
légende
pour moi c'est le monde de la photo de
presse au québec ce qui me québec sam ap
il était un peu notre lataste ericsson à
tous les sens du terme
antoine désilets a été embauché par le
journal la presse en 1961 il a
immortalisé les grands événements de son
époque comme ici la crise d'octobre de
1970 en campagne électorale
antoine ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils montraient pas nécessairement
seulement que le chien du parti il ya
l'espagne qui faisait quelques photos se
dépêcha fait quelques photos les
politiques ma pression il sauvé puis
aller faire des photos un peu partout
dans les rues
parmi ses meilleures photographies il y
à celles des beatles en concert de
pauline julien et de johnny hallyday il
est un des seuls à voir aussi bien
photographier rené lévesque et innover
avec un style qu'on voyait pas à
l'époque avait beaucoup de photo grand
angle beaucoup d'humour dans ses photos
de jouer que les invente la les arrières
plaint d'être des hyper créatif d'avoir
un petit clin d'oeil humoristique
d'aller au lieu de même parce que tout
le monde allait spi à côté au tibia
gauche ni à droite
79 antoine désilets a reçu près de 90
prix ici comme à l'international
après son passage à la presse et au
journal le jour en 1976 il s'est mise à
l'écriture et à l'enseignement la photo
récemment il a eu droit à une grande
exposition à drummondville
près de quarante trois mille
photographies réalisées par antoine
désilets sont conservés à bibliothèque
et archives nationales du québec
plusieurs peuvent être vues sur internet
ou sur place
on peut penser c'est le souhait de
monsieur délègue donc les photographes
amateurs professionnels
peuvent utiliser s'inspirer de son
oeuvre antoine désilets avait toujours
son appareil photo au cou même jusqu'à
son dernier souffle nous raconte son
fils c'était planifie sa marque
assistance médicale et rousseau et
c'était prévu depuis la veille il
fallait que je veux y mettre l'appareil
photo ou coup avant que avant que le
médecin procède cette photographie d'un
coucher de soleil aura été sa dernière
une image qui brille de tous ses feux
ici luigi de queen radio canada montréal